vingt ans après avoir mis un terme à sa
brillante carrière de joueur michel
platini prend les rênes de l'uefa une
élection serrée mais le président
sortant
lennart johansson qui brigue un
cinquième mandat a dû s'incliner la
victoire de michel platini c'est la
victoire d'une autre vision du football
didier chant michel platini encore sous
le coup de l'émotion a bien du mal à
réaliser qu'une nouvelle carrière
s'ouvre à lui font vient ensuite la face
à sion de pouvoir l'accolade entre le
vainqueur et le vaincu
michel platini élu président du foot
européen pour quatre ans à la faveur de
27 voix contre 23 résidents sortant
lennart johansson
comme j'étais footballeur quand on avait
une grande victoire
on recevait une coupe et puis avec ses
amis on faisait le tour du terrain
aujourd'hui c'est une grande victoire
pour moi mais je fais pas le tour du
terrain parce que tout va commencer
c'est le début d'une aventure sitôt la
victoire acquise
l'ancien capitaine des bleus est allé
embrasser ses parents michel platini va
maintenant devoir se mettre au travail
pour tenir ses engagements
c'est un vaste chantier qui l'attend
objectifs prioritaires du nouveau patron
de l'europe du foot remettre le football
au coeur des préoccupations de l'uefa le
football mesdames et messieurs est un
jeu avant d'être un produit
le football est un sport avant d'être un
marché est le football est un spectacle
avant d'être un business
sa vision pour l'avenir du foot comme sa
carrière politique ont réellement pris
naissance en 98 cette année là il avait
aussi apporté son soutien à cette
blatter pour son élection à la tête du
foot mondial
aujourd'hui michel platini a sans doute
bénéficié du réseau d'affluence du grand
argentier du foot
conjugué à une excellente campagne de
terrain et un programme séduisant michel
cet avantage d'abord un européen et que
on est content que tout football le feu
européen avec lui puisse se développer
parce que il ya aucune société qui
fonctionne quand il y en a que quatre ou
cinq qui grandissent et que les autres
moeurs petit qui donc je suis vraiment
vraiment heureux que michel soient
passés avec des vraies idées sur le sur
le football désormais le plus dur
commence pour michel platini reste à
savoir s'il pourra ou non tenir ses
promesses de campagne